To some,
he was the very embodiment of evil,
the psychopathic incarnation
of the devil himself.
To others,
he was a god fearing
defender of the faith,
courageously standing up to the
feared Ottoman Empire in his time,
he was known as Vlad the impaler thanks
to his favorite method of executing
people today,
though we remember him as the real life
inspiration for bram stoker's infamous
prince of darkness.
In this week's biographics,
we discover the gruesome truth
about the real flat Dracula,
Vlad Dracula future prints of where
they here was born in either November or
December of 14,
31 in the northern Romanian state.
If we lay here,
his father flap.
The second was to become ruler of flakier.
In the year of his second son's birth,
Vlad senior joined in 90 society
known as the order of the dragons.
Upon his induction,
he was given the surname draggle,
which is a derivative of Drac,
meaning dragon in ancient Romanian.
However,
in the modern Romanian language,
this means devil.
His son was given the name for
some of that being dracula,
the world of land was born into.
It was a violent one,
consumed with disputes over
territory and rulership,
family name and Ana were
the most important thing,
something which was drummed
into the boy from the start.
He also understood that the goal was
to push the boundaries of the empire
regardless of the cost,
the order of the Dragon,
which Vlad scene he became a part of,
was committed to defending
Christianity against the haters.
Ottoman Turks at the
time of his son's birth,
Vad.
The second served as a guard commander
in the mountain passes and we're like
here,
we don't actually know who've lads,
mother was when Vlad was born.
His father was married
to princess and nature,
but he also had a string of mistresses
and anyone could have given birth to the
future.
Dracula lands formative
years were spent in ct,
so IRA,
when his father ascended to the
throne of weather here in 1436,
he brought Vlad and his younger brother
Ragu to live in the royal court in the
capital.
The boys.
It would have been educated at home by
Greek and Roman scholars who their father
had brought in from Constantinople.
They would have busied themselves with
learning the rudiments of mathematics,
geography,
science,
and languages including old church,
slavonic,
German,
and Latin,
that's their privileged upbringing,
was rudely interrupted when their father
was ousted as real of a rival group who
were in league with the Hungarians.
Glad senior built an alliance
with the Ottoman Sea,
agreed to help him regain his throne
on the proviso that he paid tribute to
Sultan macramed the seconds and so that
he leave his two sons at the Ottoman
court as a guarantee of his loyalty
labs had no choice and the two boys were
seized and made prisoners,
although relatively well treated,
the boys were able to observe the Turkish
use of Taran as an instrument in order
to achieve ends.
This was something which Vlad would use
to great effect nature in his own life
while in the Ottoman court.
So the boys were able to further their
education being instructed in logic,
the Turkish language and
the teachings of the Koran.
They were also given lessons
in horsemanship and warfare.
The two brothers differ markedly and
their attitude towards their captivity.
Roger,
either younger brother,
he accepted the situation and embraced
his new life and the teachings that came
with it,
it would eventually converted Islam
and to service in the Ottoman court.
Vlad,
however,
resistant as every turn,
despite constant punishments for is
certainly attitudes with the assistance of
the Turks.
Lads senior was able to regain his throne,
but this wasn't something
that lasted in 14.
40 seven Hungarian backs,
rebels attacked again,
forcing Vlad and his oldest son Messier
the second to fleet both were eventually
captured and put to death.
The next in line to the throne of
winter here was vlad the third,
his older brother,
but he had become a monk
and lived in a monastery.
This left Vlad who is now 16 as
the rightful heir to the throne.
Despite his obstinate and see the
Turks had grown fond of the teenager.
They vowed to help him regain his throne,
which they did with an overthrow
of the rebel ruler in 1448.
As soon as the Ottomans left,
however,
the Hungarians were back and within
two months flat was forced to flee to
Moldova for the next three years.
He lived there under the protection and
tutelage of his uncle Prince Bogdan the
seconds,
but when Bogdan was assassinated in 1450,
one flat again,
fled this time along with
his cousin print steven,
the two young men ended up in Transylvania
where they came onto the mentorship
of a Hungarian warrior named John,
who knew Yardi.
He was a power broker who was fiercely
opposed to the Ottoman Empire from Yardi,
had originally supported the new
ruler of a man by the name of gladys.
Love the seconds,
but the relationship it
quickly disintegrated.
This was thanks largely to that slavs
appeasement of the Turks when Vladislav
invaded in several
villages in Transylvania.
When yardies patients,
it's simply gave out,
he looks young blast to take back the
throne that rightfully belonged to him.
In the same year,
14,
53,
the holy Roman city of Constantinople
fell to the Ottoman Turks.
It's now appeared as if the whole
of Europe was theirs for the taking.
The securing of way here became
more important than ever,
and in 14,
56 land led an army into the area.
He meets the army of Lattice
love on the field of battle,
ended up killing the usurper in hand to
hand combat with the death of gladys.
Slava.
Vlad was restored power as the ruler
of Lakeea over the next six years,
he would rule with an
unprecedented bloodlust that
would cement his name forever
in the annals of merciless monarchs,
having secured the throne
of Lakeea for himself,
God sends a portion of his army
over the border to help his cousin,
steven,
to secure the throne of Moldova.
When this was accomplished,
the two cousins held sway over
a large swath of the Balkans,
proving a powerful strong hold against
the tax lads now set his mind on revenge.
He had his spies go and find the names
of any nobles who had even been remotely
involved in the plot to
overthrow his father.
Having collected a list of names of
lads invited the men to an Easter feast
along with their families,
but as soon as the traders arrived,
they were arrested.
The older among them
were impaled venom there,
right in front of their families.
Those who are younger,
we're forced into slavery,
laboring to rebuild Vlads causal.
When this job was done,
the they were all killed vlads treatments
of the traitors to his father's reign.
It was just the beginning.
He next proceeded to enforce his own
stringent moral code on the entire
population.
Any deviation was met
with unthinkable cruelty.
He seemed to be especially
concerned with female chastity.
Any woman who lost her virginity prior
to marriage or who defiled the marriage
bed would be impaled with the
insertion points being the vagina.
More often than not,
their breasts would also be cut off
with a man with whom they had committed
fornication.
Being forced to eat them.
Labs also has a hatred of
beggars considering them
to be existing off the hard
work of others.
It is said that he once invited all the
baggers in with her to a massive feast
in a centrally located,
wouldn't hold one day at Eaton,
do their full.
He is said to have ordered the
doors bolted in the building,
set on fire.
In this way,
he is said to have read his
realm of the scourge of poverty
on the international scene.
The ultimate threads was
becoming more ominous.
In 1460,
Pope Pius the second held a congress that
man to her initially calling for a new
crusade to reclaim constantinople and
push the Ottomans back to the desert.
The crusade was to last for three years
and will be led by Mathias Covinas.
He was the son of John in Yardi,
who had been killed during
an invasion of Serbia.
Martinez,
made a tour of European kingdoms
seeking support for the enterprise.
The only ruler who gave a
positive response was flat.
Dracula overlay here determines to
hold his kingdom safe from the texts.
He formed an alliance
with Mathias veinous,
the Ottomans,
meanwhile,
well aware of the lack of
support for this new crusade.
Sultan Mac mid the second
seized the advantage by
capturing the last independent
Serbian city smatter Rovio.
During this campaign,
the Hungarian general.
Now Holly says Lagi was taken captive.
This general was knowns of lads
having helps put down a revolt in 15,
48.
When Vlad heard that he had been sought
in half his blood boils and he became
more committed than ever to teaching the
Ottomans a lesson that they would never
forget.
The ultimate empire extended degrees in
40 slash 61 when the we grew surrendered
without putting up any defense.
Now,
both Corinth and the capital
of Mr were ruled by the Turks.
The sultan also had his sights on here.
He declared it to be part of the
Ottoman Empire as song she sent envoys,
Div Lance Castle in order to collect a
tribute of 10,000 buckets along with 500
men to be taken into.
The TAC is Shami,
but the sultan had
underestimated the young ruler
when the sultans,
envoys,
refused to lift that Tibetans
as a sign of respect to him.
Vlad became enraged and times is God's
drive nails through their turbans and
into their skulls the incredible assault
and responded by sending his army
across the Danube in order to seize the
men and bring them back to become a part
of his army.
Lot centers forces to the area to
grab any tax that could be found.
They will soon impaled on red
hot stakes towards the end of 14,
61 bladder wrote to the salt and informing
him that he could not afford to pay a
tribute,
but that he was coming to Constantinople
and was ready to negotiate.
Macramed was aware of of laddered
already aligned himself with the crusade,
so we decided to take the way he and
ruler who her dad to murder his invoice by
force.
He sent one of his generals along with
a thousand strong cavalry to meet with
land with the intention of ambushing him,
but Vlad got wind of the plan that's
put into operation is I an ambush as the
approaching tax.
We're negotiating their way through
a narrow traverse that and army they
attacked.
It hasn't been reported.
That vlans attack was one of the first
instances where gun powder was used.
Apparently two deadly effects.
The dogs work ells with many of them
suffering of lance favorite torture,
and that was of course
impalements with his blood.
Now,
up flat took his army across the Danube
River where they attacked Ottoman
controlled areas in Bulgaria
between Saudi or in the Black Sea,
were given advanced,
do fortify towns and use his
skills in the Turkish language.
Do encourage the gods do open the gates,
then is Ami would pour in from over
the horizon that would then go into a
killing frenzy.
Slaughtering every Turkish man,
woman or child that he could find.
Over a period of two weeks,
he lead his army over
an area of 500 miles,
carrying around 23,000
people in February of 14,
62 vlad ropes in glowing terms to Mathias
covinas about what he had accomplished
in red.
I've killed peasant men and women,
young and old who lived at oblong sits
on and Novo Selo where the Danube flows
into the sea up to [inaudible],
which is located near chillier from the
lower Danube to such places as some of
us and Gagan.
We Killed Twenty 3,884 tax
without counting those,
and we burned in homes or the tax
whose heads were cut by our soldiers.
Thus,
your highness,
you must know I've broken the piece and
outraged Sultan ordered his grand vizier
Mac mode with 18,000 troops to destroy
a port in well Lakeea Code Brailler.
This force was intercepted by
Vlad and this 30,000 strong army.
The Turks were utterly defeated with
only 8,000 of them surviving these quick
five victories and flat,
a heroic reputation throughout Europe.
Even the pope praised
him at the same time,
his reputation as the impaler king
served to intimidate the Turkish people,
many of whom plans the European part
of the Ottoman Empire for Anatolia in
response to the slaughter and the fear
that Vlad had caused amongst his people.
Salton macramed abandoned his campaign
and Greece and turns his attention to the
problem.
He gathered an army of 150,000 people
with the sole mission of finding and
killing.
Vlad.
The Sultan had already
promised the rulership of
relay here to of lands younger
brother Randy with himself after the head,
the Salton set out to find and kill flat
payless
force of around 13,000.
We're not saying the hugely outnumbered.
They were also hopelessly out classed
as far as weaponry was concerned.
They carried only launces and daggers,
whereas the text had in their midst
squadrons of deadly arches along with
powerful siege and muscle weaponry.
Despite this Vlad was able to inflict
major casualties upon the sultans forces,
he followed a scorched earth policy
as he moved away from the approaching.
Tax Wells were poisoned
with entire populations,
including animals being evacuated,
also engaged in guerrilla
fighting tactics.
Hit and run.
Raids were made on the sultan's army and
as a primitive type of germ warfare was
also utilized were men who were
afflicted with the bubonic plague,
was sent in Turkish towns,
do in fact as many people as possible.
The tactic works with the
plague spreading to the sultans.
Men in the end though,
the efforts of lads,
men were no more than an irritant
to the vastly superior Turkish army.
Steadily.
They moved on getting ever closer to the
castle when they arrived there and does
24,000 men,
strong army were holed up in the mountain
refuge just outside of the city of
that who was now faced with
an encircled by the Turks,
which would eventually forces army
into starvation did something quite
extraordinary even for him leaving
his men behind in the mountains.
He disguised himself and walked directly
into the Turkish army encampments.
He quickly determines the
position of the sultans tent.
He founds out that the sultan had given
the order for his men to remain in their
tents at night in order to prevent panic
in the event of an attack even quietly
slipped out of the camp and
returned back to his own men,
lads,
and help set about planning a
surprise attack on the sultan's army.
It was his personal intention to enter.
The sultans tends to drive a knife through
Mac meds heart on the night of June
the 17,
14,
62,
he divided his forces into two man's
then attacked from both the north and the
south.
The Turks were caught off guard allowing
the attackers to inflect heavy losses
within an hour of savage fighting.
More than 15,000 Turks were slaughtered
at a cost of some five thousands of lads
men.
He himself succeeded in entering the
tents that he had previously picked out.
The only problem was that he had selected
the wrong tense and founds no salt and
insight.
A daybreak flags cooled off the attack
and his men melted back into the
mountains.
The sultan was so despondent
that he pulled back and
was prepared to retreat all
the way back across the Denewb.
However,
he was convinced by his generals that
success with still within their grasp and
so he led his men into the capital city.
When they arrived in [inaudible],
the tilex founds an abandoned city.
They also found the remains of 20,000
Turkish soldiers killed in previous
conflicts and impaled on steaks.
At this site,
the sultan is said to have remarked,
a man who has done such things is worth
much with nothing to do in the empty
city the sultan installed,
do as the new ruler of delay here,
and then turned and began to retrace
his steps back to the denewb rather than
the younger brother of labs.
Now I'm talking as forces and circled
vlads castle and located on a cliff just
outside of the city lands.
First wife within the castle legend has
it that she found to feed herself to the
fishes rather than full to the tax.
Apparently she threw herself from
the walls into the river below.
Rather,
you set about solidifying his position.
Meanwhile,
the Sultan had taken his army airway to
brayleigh where the town was destroyed
and hundreds were killed.
Vlad knew that he had to regroup and
gather a larger force if he was have any
chance of regaining control of relay.
Here he made his way to Hungary
where he sought the help of his ally.
Macias Cornice Matteo's
appeared to give us support,
even making battle plans with labs.
However,
covertness had secretly
turned against his old ally.
You organized the plans,
you ambush vlad.
The impaler was taken
as this prison prisoner.
The reason for Matty as this change
of loyalty has been debated now for
centuries with the consensus being that
he wanted to become holy Roman emperor
and knew that an end to hostilities
with the tax was needed before they can
become a reality land spent the next
four years as a prisoner and hungry.
During this time,
he converted to Catholicism.
He also met king metastasis,
cousin having softened his
attitude towards this prisoner.
Mateus allowed the to to marry.
Apparently he was released just prior to
the ceremony land and his new wife were
given a house.
It passed.
It was under strict
instructions not to return to.
We're like,
yeah,
this.
He had no intention of giving up on the
crown that still rightly belongs to him.
He secretly collaborations with
a former military commander.
They managed to gather together and Ami
consisting of a mixture of Hungarian
Transylvanian well Adrian and Moldavia
and forces of land set out with his
makeshift Ami in the
middle of 1476 by now.
His younger brother Randy would died and
they had been replaced by Prince busop.
The elder before flatted
even God photography shared
the Saab and his army had
flat.
Vlad was placed on the throne
and the army largely dissolved.
Labs was back in power,
but he lacked a strong army.
In fact,
he only had around 4,000 men to draw upon,
so when the tax returns two months
after his retaking of the throne,
he was soundly defeated.
The exact details surrounding his
death are a master of some debates.
Most scholars agree that he was killed
while fighting the techs in early 14,
77,
a contemporary Turkish
chronicle a recorded that the
tax killed and decapitated
him,
sending his head back to Constantinople.
There it is,
said to have been presented in honey
and to put on display so that everyone
could see that the graduate
impaler was really finally debt.
It is estimated that Vlans,
legacy of execution methods included
more than 20,000 impalements,
5,000 beheadings,
10,000 burnings at stake,
tend to x.
You had nails driven through that turbans
and at least one who was boiled alive
and then cannibalized,
yet in his home country of
Romania flat is seen as a hero.
Here's an important national figure,
a god fearing it.
Who stood up to the Ottoman Empire?
Well,
I guess it all depends
on your perspective,
so I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel
for brand new biographies every Monday
and every Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel that's called
today I found out it's sort of like
biographics,
but way more broad on that channel.
We get deep into all of the details
on all sorts of interesting stuff.
Check it out through the
link on the screen now,
but if you're looking for
something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography
from the archives or today?
Found out video over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.